all right spring weather calls for
spring grain bowls i spoke to a chef
from readyset.com that wants to cut the
time and the calories for your family
meal plan
rebecca welcome to las vegas now
thank you
i am so excited to see these recipes you
are from readysete.com
and we're talking grain bowls because
you know it's springtime the weather's
getting warmer people are you know
stepping out in their spring and summer
attire and wanting to change their diets
and be a little healthier so let's talk
about what's first on the menu the first
one i want to show you is a mongolian
beef
and i'm using brown rice i always like
to throw some
power greens in with the grains and then
what i've done here is i've just taken
some some sirloin that i've
cut uh very like thinly and i've just
used um
not even anything complicated i'm just
using a
pf chang's mongolian style barbecue
sauce so very easy that's a good idea
marinate it for 20 minutes and then cook
it up with some bok choy
probably a great ingredient and then
what's fun about rainbows is i think if
you're new to plating dishes
it's really easy to
make them look wow without a lot of
without a lot of technique required and
then i'm going to add some i love to put
some fresh crunchy vegetables on with
this as well it's like a nice hot and
cold uh sweet and salty this barbecue
sauce a little a little speech carrots
are sweet so i'm putting that in another
corner of the bowl here this is just
edamame frozen edamame
adding some more protein in there
and then um just
just fresh red cabbage adds that nice
crunch that you said that you like
and then some um i've just got some and
really a lot of ingredients can go with
any of these flavors right i've just
been scallion to freshen it up and then
to make it look real fancy i've just
mixed together some black sesame seeds
and some white
sesame seeds they've been toasted i like
to have these on hand
we call it a tuxedo mix and it's just
kind of it makes it all of a sudden
elevates your dish so now it looks like
you are eating at a restaurant
and then just a little extra drizzle of
sauce on top
and then you have this beautiful
colorful
nutritious
grain bowl that everyone can kind of
customize to their own liking and you
can do um some uh some fish if you like
um you can start with this one i did
with quinoa again with the grains i'm
just gonna put a piece of salmon right
in the middle there
and then for this one it's like a fish
taco unwrapped fish taco fish taco bowl
so i'm going to add some fun flavors to
this one as well i've got some some
fresh mango and then i love putting
fresh radishes on my tacos so i'm going
to throw some of those in there too that
i've just julienned and again it's just
so easy to make this
um and then i'm actually going to put
some salsa on top of this i'm using
frontera tomatillo salsa and then some
fresh cilantro and then the crunchy like
you said um like like loving crunchy
these are just um these are frontera the
lime ones i love the long ones they add
a nice
extra kick of flavor and then you have
this
again beautiful grain bowl that people
can kind of pick and choose what they
want to go on it
you were laughing